avec nous maintenant vous le connaissez
bien charge philippe david président de
l'observatoire sur les états-unis de
l'uqam bonsoir jean philippe bonsoir
c'est le grand plaisir de vous retrouver
oui plaisir de notre côté également donc
monsieur byden défense est ce retrait
des troupes américaines
mais on sent que c'est peut-être la
première vraie crise politique à
laquelle il est confronté à quel point
ça lui nuit je pense qu'à court terme
certainement saluant nuit parce que les
chiffres ne mentent pas céline coûté en
un mois les appuis pour joe biden dans
l'opinion publique ont fortement diminué
et si bien d'ailleurs que les derniers
sondages nous donnent moins de 50% un
peu en bas de 50% pour la première fois
de sa présidence
d'appui aux de son opinion publique
maintenant à moyen terme ou à long terme
qu'est ce qui lie le message que les
américains vont retenir est-ce qu'ils
vont retenir qu'il a livré la
marchandise est tenu promesse c'est à
dire de mettre fin à cette guerre
interminable de 20 ans comme d'ailleurs
il avait dit durant sa campagne
électorale où est-ce qu'ils vont retenir
toutes ces images c'est pas fini je
pense d'ailleurs ces images de de drame
humanitaire de deux sorties bac l'est de
l'afghanistan et puis même voire de la
reprise de la violence en afghanistan et
espérons pas non plus de la reprise du
terroriste sort évidemment ça serait le
message plutôt négatif et qui nuiraient
joe biden oui en même temps il a été
trés
vindicatif aujourd'hui on est en
expliquant aux américains qu'il fallait
aussi faire face à une certaine réalité
parce que si à l'origine de cette
intervention il fallait capturé ossama
ben laden tout ça et chasser al qaïda et
vous faire disparaître al-qaïda tout ça
a été fait d'une certaine façon mais
tout le reste aura été un échec depuis
vingt ans la reconstruction la
démocratie tout ça aucun doute là dessus
pour toutes ces raisons et plus encore
que vous venez de mentionner
exemple la corruption un puma
rampante en afghanistan qui a représenté
un problème épouvantable le fait que ce
gouvernement finale n'est pas acquis du
tout la légitimité de la population et
surtout même voire de ses soldats être
son appareil de sécurité qui imaginaient
se sont ralliés aux talibans donc oui
c'est un c'est un gâchis est ce qu'on va
retenir je pense c'est que cette guerre
je le rappelle donc on le dit cette
guerre sans fin et bien n'aura pas
accompli vraiment l'objectif plus large
de la démocratie et de la sécurité et
que probablement à l'avenir il n'y aura
aucun appétit céline mais alors aucun
appétit pour ce genre d'intervention
d'intervention onusienne américaine
otanienne pour construire dit on des
nations ça je pense que ça vient de
sceller vraiment la fin de ce type de
guerre il faut pas oublier que ça
coûtait il a précisé 300 millions de
dollars par jour aux américains cette
guerre et 7 cette occupation aussi du
pays oui cet argent ne s'est pas rendue
chez n'est ce pas tous les afghans il ya
beaucoup de gens au sein du gouvernement
qui se sont qui se sont enrichis donc le
problème de l'imputabilité est resté
vraiment entier en afghanistan non c'est
vraiment la fin le 31 ou 2021 d'une
grande étape de cette politique
étrangère américaine qui pendant les 20
dernières années a été quand même
largement interventionniste et puis déjà
on a vu avec trempe que la pythie n'y
était plus je le répète et la job hayden
donc tient cette promesse maintenant il
faudra voir ce qui va arriver en
afghanistan parce que la suède est chose
en afghanistan où les américains se sont
sortis sont sortis de l'afghanistan mais
non pas régler le problème de
l'afghanistan et les problèmes sont
multiples alors on verra ce n'est pas
fini les talibans sont au pouvoir il ya
déjà des milices qui conteste ce pouvoir
est ce qu'ils vont être capables sur le
plan diplomatique de convaincre quelques
et avoir tous les états de les
reconnaître sur le plan diplomatique
enfin il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions en suspens est ce que je
trouve intéressant dans cette sortie de
crise c'est probablement les principaux
bénéficiaires du retrait américain
d'afghanistan ça risque d'être la chine
lâche et qui a déjà conclu des ententes
avec le gouvernement taliban qui ne veut
pas problème de sécurité évidemment dans
la région ouigours qui ne veut pas que
des terroristes we go attaques
perpétrées face des attentats en chine
alors c'est la russie aussi la russie
qui va vouloir protéger ses frontières 1
6l de l'asie centrale l'iran le pakistan
qui vont être aux premières loges du
drame déjà humanitaire qui risque de ne
pas du tout du tout s'estomper bref
c'est pas fini du tout avec
l'afghanistan c'est sûr oui il ya encore
des américains qui sont en afghanistan
même ça aussi c'est un peu risqué très
bien mais on va suivre ça peut-être avec
vous merci beaucoup c'est un fait mais
je vous emplit ces lieux